mona rebonjour alors je le disais tout à
l'heure est ce que les pompiers sont
bien rassembler derrière
en effet amira ils sont bien à sangler
derrière moi je peux vous dire qu'ils
sont assez nombreux ici ici place de la
république ce cortège qui vous l'avez
dit va démarrer
ce comité qui atterrira à place de la
nation vous l'avez dit le manifeste
contre la réforme des retraites mais pas
seulement
demande également plus d'hommes orient
et mansle et surtout une revalorisation
de cette prime de funk et de 19% il
avala 28% il ya déjà eu plusieurs rendez
vous entre l'intersyndicale dès sa part
le ministre de l'intérieur je suis
justement avec l'index va nous en dire
un petit peu moins bon jour à vous vous
appelez renault vous êtes de la cgt et
que vous venez de montauban dit-on
aujourd'hui parce que c'est important
pour vous de manifester alors qu'il ya
déjà eus avec le ministre de l'intérieur
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a été très très
très peu entendu parler nistos
l'intérieur en plus on a les indications
depuis le mois de juin les dernières on
me demande d'être entendu et c'est très
limité pour demander une augmentation de
la prime de feu
l'équité avec la police avec une
proposition très limité jusqu'à la
semaine dernière à 25% l'ornement de 28%
à côté une augmentation des agressions
sur les abords bon pied
due à des phénomènes sociétaux aussi
également
justement naissance elle est surtout des
garanties par rapport à notre retraite
future
la gale aujourd'hui on enrage surcotiser
nous l'appuyons fait n'y a pas de
problème sur les régimes de retraite
particulier voilà vous demander aussi à
partir plus tôt à la retraite
en fait on devant la partir plus tôt
mais on les chiots cotisent tout ça
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui en fait on
demande à partir plus tôt mais on paye
les années sur les années en fait
comment vous dire
on doit pas 62 à 52 7 à ce que les âmes
et les cinq ans qu'on avait en fait on
est sûr cotiseront les pays doivent être
ça coûte rien à personne nous payons nos
retraites en fait notre régime dit qu
des communes alentour
aujourd'hui nous on connaît en tant qu
on connaît les difficultés de votre
métier
j'évoque plus de reconnaissance que
c'est un métier qui est à risque
oui c'est ça d'où la prime gonnehem en
fête aujourd'hui on a une feuille 2%
étaient donnés depuis des années
aujourd'hui la police à matthew goss
avec une prime à risque nous on veut
juste passer une prime à risque comme eu
en équité en fait c'est tout ce qu'on
demande aujourd'hui vous avez conçu un
système
même si le gouvernement
vraisemblablement ne vous a pas
convaincu la méditation aujourd'hui
aller
c'est le point
deux rencontres par rapport aux
dernières propositions qui sont trop
basses eaux aujourd'hui c'est pour faire
massivement qu'on est là et qu'il faut
nous entendre et qu'ils nous prennent en
compte en fait d en considération au
service contenu qu'on fait la population
je pense qu'on est présente tous les
jours on aimerait juste à d'écouter ses
tubes qu'on demande si beaucoup à vous
pour ce témoignage
bon courage à vous l'avez entendu à me
rater des sapeurs pompiers qui restent
mobilisés qui vont tuer ni fessées je
vous lisez vous l'aurez peut-être
derrière moi y'a beaucoup on entendait
des pétards on entende
il ya également beaucoup de fumigènes
qui sont lancés cette manifestation et
maintient d'ici qui a culminé qui vont
défiler dans le mariage la place de la
nation
merci pour toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous étiez en direct de
place de la république